not only was it super bowl fever
but over in hollywood
there was the sag award announcement
yeah and you remember last week if you
watched the show we were all we were in
mourning literally a black veil when
bridgerton was snubbed it was it was a
terrible day for us well guess what
chin's up everybody because at the sag
awards bridgeton nominated for best
ensemble which is their version of best
show and uh reggae jean page was
nominated for best actor our friend
remember phoebe denavere and reggae
jean-page came and visited us
at the news desk
so we're just so happy for them and the
emmys is next and you know thank you i
feel like the sags righted the wrong
that the globes did so the world is back
to normal everybody calm down you've got
super bowl yeah
sag awards for hollywood fans and pop
culture and then there is more exciting
news and this for me might be the most
meaningful of them all time magazine
just released their new cover featuring
poet laureate amanda gorman
superstar i am
a little bit shaky right now about how
much i love her and the super bowl was
also smart enough to have her do a
reading from the inauguration to the
super bowl to time magazine i also feel
like a true renaissance is going to
happen all due to her
poetry expression
words
everything is going to version because
of this one
young woman who is changing the game
single-handedly and yet she's gonna have
the greatest effect on us all and um the
time magazine is the black renaissance
double issue she's interviewed by
michelle obama but i'm like from
inauguration to the super bowl to time
magazine amanda gorman she talks about
struggling with speech issues something
that she has in common with president
biden and another poet maya angelou
who people have said she is an
embodiment of um she studied to become a
better writer and amanda is such a rock
star and a bright light go get this
issue yeah it's pretty incredible the
hottest person in show business right
now is a poet laureate right named
amanda gorman amazing and just having
such a moment all right the next story
drew comes to us from new orleans mardi
gras is coming up just next week are you
ready and even though the parades have
been canceled for the first time in 40
years people are still finding a way to
celebrate you can't keep people down
when they want to celebrate mardi gras
people reports new orleans residents are
turning their homes into mardi gras
floats yeah check these out we got
pictures these were done by artists and
just everyday people who wouldn't be
brought down by the pandemic they are
adapting to the year and keeping this
incredibly rich tradition alive i love
this i've never been to mardi gras i've
been in new orleans but i'd love to go
one day i'm just afraid people would try
to give me beads to keep my top on you
know
but have you ever been i did i did go to
mardi gras and oh it was so much fun but
don't you love don't you love it these
people just said yeah we can't have a
parade we can't do what we normally do
and these are prey people down there
that they just said we're gonna do it
our way i just love the look of the
homes too i just you know they saved
mardi gras they did okay and next up is
a story of a man who saves something
else that's very precious
this story really really really speaks
to me ross
so the new york post reports that this
garbage truck driver in ohio well
he saw something like moving in the
garbage he saw like a backpack actually
like shape-shifting and he went
and he picked it up and he unzipped it
and inside
was a abandoned puppy oh my gosh you're
trying to kill me drew i know yeah and
look she's um getting it she he took her
to the vet
she got treated and ultimately he said
you know what i think we found each
other and i'm gonna adopt her there is a
reason that man saw that bag move and
this is one of those stories that if
you're having a bad day and a story like
this pops up on your news feed it's for
a reason too because it makes you
remember there's so there's so much
goodness in the world i find out i found
out about it and it just overtook my
whole day it just gave me that hope the
look in both of their eyes
i just i really i really took this one
to heart i have to say yeah thank you i
read it in one of those moments when i
needed a good story and there it was me
too that's exactly right rossi well we
hope it was a good story for you another
thing that makes people feel real good a
good old-fashioned rom-com yeah give me
a puppy and a rom-com honey you won't
i'll i'm good all right by the way
true
yeah it'll won't it cure nothing exactly
and now apartment therapy says a new
study crunched the numbers to find out
what was the most watched rom-com on
valentine's day uh now drew and i are
we're reading this for the first time i
said i don't want to know what it is me
too you don't know okay
you know ross and i like to do things
fresh if we play a game here we do not
know the questions let alone the answers
we like spontaneous reactions you can
never get it back once you know so keep
it fresh plus we're really bad liars i
mean can't fake it okay so 2020 and the
number one movie for valentine's day was
for reals the princess bride oh god
that's for everyone good for everyone if
you haven't seen that that's an oldie
but a good oh you have to i show my
daughters and i play it all the time
what about this one uh
this one i can understand pretty woman
mm-hmm which one uh it took two years in
a row before uh the princess bride won
uh hello pretty woman do you know that
was really originally called three
thousand yes i do because he paid her
three thousand dollars i love that you
know that because i just found out i
just found that out yeah there was a
different ending too and we actually
work with raja gosnell who is the editor
of pretty woman and the director i've
never been kissed so yes i tried to get
every piece of information
i'm googling it later it's so cool all
right oh there's also a map of the most
popular uh february 14th rom-coms in
every single state and it looks like
washington and california where i'm from
where you're from they went for princess
bride but our state where we live now in
new york they left crazy rich asians in
2020 which is a great movie i was just
going to say i just was watching that
the other night with olive we love that
movie so much well you know and i was
i'm looking here too you should go to
minnesota next in hawaii uh because 50
first dates was their favorite
it's banned it's been number one there
for three years in a row
oh my gosh well first of all hawaii is
so great because that's where we made it
yeah um but minnesota
i'm so honored i love minnesota that's
so cool congrats to you oh my god thank
you minnesota thank you hawaii and
speaking of valentine's day if you have
a special little cutie that you want to
impress or if you just want a snack to
go along with your rom-com marathon well
we've got just the thing for you today
in today's food news
that makes me laugh every time so
refinery29 is shared the mother of all
valentine's gifts um it's a meat bouquet
oh thank god finally somebody invented
it look at that
well and you know flowers are nice deer
but it's been done i think this is a
great idea if somebody let me tell you i
mean you send me tulips great i'm in but
if you send me a bouquet of chicken
fingers i will you can get it all right
there is nothing i love the chicken the
finger is the the best part of the
chicken everyone knows that
right
i think this is a great idea and think
about for men if you're searching for
your husband or something get him a meat
bouquet he'll love it
i think you all know what i'm thinking
um
well anyway food 52 is who recommended
that you go to olympia provisions and
get your loved one a
meat bouquet today
[Music]